good afternoon
my name is lisa yang and i'm the
co-founder of the k lisa yang and hop
e10 center for molecular therapeutics in
neuroscience at mit
for the next hour four scientists from
the mcgovern institute will with you
from today's surreal pandemic alice in
wonderland world
of the mad hatter and the mad tea party
to look into some of the most exciting
cutting edge research underway at the
center
that's paving the way for novel brain
disorder therapies
across the world there are millions of
families who are living with chronic
complex and more often than not
debilitating brain disorders
including autism parkinson's
schizophrenia
depression and epilepsy i believe it's
vital to create opportunities that
enable individuals with all kinds of
abilities
to thrive and lead meaningful lives but
for many people with profound and
intractable brain disorders
today's treatments are lacking
indeed for the past several decades
true therapeutic breakthroughs for the
most severe forms of brain disorders
have been few and far between
some of the challenges touch on very
tough problems
the scientists have been grappling with
for many years
such as more effective ways to deliver
therapies
across the blood-brain barrier on new
gene therapy
tools that can treat disease and its
root genetic mutation
rather than help to make incremental
progress
i'm willing to invest in the exploration
of
non-conventional ideas
i'm hopeful than a new lens on
revolutionary technologies that harness
genetic and molecular discoveries as
well as unorthodox computational and
engineering approaches
can be successful in the search for
effective therapeutics
the goal of the center is to take these
new therapeutic tools for the toughest
neurological diseases
to clinical trials during this decade
it is my expectation that the
discoveries made in the center
will extend well beyond the brain and
shape future treatments for a multitude
of diseases
i will now let the brilliant scientists
at the mcgovern institute give you a
sneak peek
into the incredible and game-changing
potential
of molecular therapeutics enjoy
hello i guess i'm going to be my your
guide on this sneak peek
i'm carrie goldberg i'm a health and
science reporter for wbur and i'm editor
of wbur's common health blog
i'll be moderating for the next hour as
we hear from these scientists and
i want to welcome you and thank you for
joining us today
as uh lisa said our topic is the
incredible world of molecular
therapeutics
and specifically how radical new
molecular methods
are paving the way for promising new
ways to treat
devastating brain disorders so uh before
we get started a few quick housekeeping
notes
this event is being recorded it's closed
captioned
we'll have an opportunity for you the
audience to ask our panelists
questions in the second half hour of the
discussion
if you'd like to ask a question you just
click on the q a
button at the bottom of your screen and
type it in and if you see a question
that someone else has
asked that interests you you can upvote
it by clicking the thumbs up icon next
to the question
and it's a good idea to do that because
we probably won't have time to get to
all the questions so at this point
i was planning to mention the
coronavirus pandemic and
how among the very many things it makes
harder it makes living with a brain
disorder that much harder too
but i think instead i'd like to
emphasize that i'm thrilled
not to be talking about covid19 which
i've been covering non-stop for the last
eight months
and just to share with you that probably
my very
favorite part of my job is when i get to
talk with people
like the researchers you'll hear from
today i just
i personally find their brilliance and
their diligence very
comforting especially now when we're all
kind of waiting for the science
cavalry to come save us and so i hope
that you will
too so today's topic molecular
therapeutics
let's do first a very basic definition
molecular therapeutics it's
traditionally referred to
chemicals used as therapeutic drugs like
lithium
ritalin ssris today we will be
discussing the next
generation of therapeutic molecules
these are
molecules that are designed to more
specifically target the genes
or brain regions that are relevant to a
specific
disorder so next generation molecular
therapeutics go beyond basic chemistry
using highly engineered biologics and
complexes of chemicals
and nano devices for targeted drug
delivery okay so let's start with a term
that i think is probably very
familiar to many crispr we've all been
hearing about its incredible potential
crispr is a natural defense system used
by bacteria to fend off viruses
and our panelist fung jung mcgovern
institute investigator and james and
patricia poitras professor in
neuroscience at mit
did absolutely seminal work on how
crispr could be a very effective way
of precisely cutting dna strands in the
human genome
in a few short years the crispr toolbox
has
rapidly grown we've seen the creation of
powerful new engineering techniques like
the use of
jumping genes to replace gene mutations
crispr is already being tested as a gene
therapy in clinical trials
and the results so far are promising and
crispr is just one of several
innovative breakthroughs that we'll be
talking about today with our panelists
all of them are investigators at mit's
mcgovern institute for brain research
and they're all members of the new k
lisa yang and hawk e10 center
for molecular therapeutics next up our
panelist paulina anikeva is an associate
professor in mit's department of
materials science and engineering
she's creating new ways of binding
metals to drug
molecules so that magnets can be used to
target drugs specifically to the brain
regions that are afflicted
without becoming diluted in the rest of
the body
and we'll be discussing new disease
models like those you'll hear about from
guoping feng
who is currently the poitres professor
of brain and cognitive sciences
these models are enabling scientists and
biotech firms
to test new therapeutics on brains much
closer to our own
than mouse brains our panelist ed boyden
is the y eva tan professor of
neurotechnology at mit
i usually just refer to him as
neuroengineer ed boyden
he is renowned for the development of
optogenetics by which
neuronal activity can be genetically
controlled by
light by defined wavelengths of light
it's a method that's now
in clinical trials for retinitis
pigmentosa for example
and today he'll describe how the new
tools his group is creating
are enabling scientists to tackle
neuroscience's most significant
problems such as how to successfully
move molecules
across the blood-brain barrier
you'll hear how today's panelists
continue to bring radical ideas that
sound like science fiction
into reality and how their advances
could shape
how doctors will be treating complex and
devastating diseases
like schizophrenia parkinson's bipolar
autism alzheimer's depression and others
in the near future
so the overarching theme for today is
the hope to
redefine molecular therapeutics for the
next generation
by considering how to evolve traditional
chemical and biologic drugs into smart
drugs that we can direct
in time and space um one quick note
before we get started is that
all four of our panelists are involved
in basic science and engineering they're
not
clinicians and so they can't recommend
treatments or
or give any kind of medical advice
okay so fun i'd like to start with you
we've recently seen
crispr gene editing techniques move into
clinical trials for
cancer blood disorders and blindness
among other diseases
it's going incredibly quickly actually
how are you
going about bringing crispr editing
tools to the brain
and what are the top challenges you face
as you do this
thank you carrie for the question it's
really a pleasure to be a part of this
um this really nice panel
um i made a couple slides to give
everyone a
basic sense of what we're working on um
so
in essence we've been working on
developing molecular
therapeutics for the brain and uh
molecular
molecular therapeutics are modular in
the sense that
if you think about sending a satellite
into space
what is being done is that you have a
vehicle
which is a rocket and then the payload
which is
that that satellite they're trying to
deliver
molecular therapeutics are modular in
this way too
and one of the ways that people realize
uh this is by using vehicles in the form
of a virus
we're now living through a pandemic so
virus is is very much at the center of
this
and so this is um like a virus where
scientists are able to remove everything
that is pathogenic
about the virus getting rid of the
natural
pathogenic dna from the virus and
replacing it with the payload which is
the therapeutic molecule
and so this is that modular system you
can take a virus
as the vehicle and and and fit into it
different kinds of payloads in order to
be able to carry out
the the desired therapeutic outcome that
you want to achieve
so what we have been working on over the
past number of years has been to harness
from nature's
diversity um to develop these
therapeutic molecules
nature is is probably the most brilliant
engineer there is if you just look
around us the bacteria that live
in our own in intestines to
all of the plants and all the animals
that live around us
have each developed very diverse
molecular mechanisms that may be hardest
for therapeutic applications on this
slide are
three different examples of how we have
explored nature's diversity
on the left side this is a a picture
microscope picture
of cyanobacteria these are the algae or
the pond scum that you find
in in the charles river for example
and by looking into one of the molecular
machineries in the cyanobacteria
were able to find a programmable jumping
gene
so that you can design it and program it
to be able to introduce dna sequences to
specific
locations in the genome this is very
useful for
replacing faulty genes genes that
have carried a mutation in the disease
or
to be able to introduce a new gene so
that you can
for example confer
cancer recognize recognition to a
immune cell so that you can go in and
destroy tumor cells
that it wasn't able to destroy
effectively before
over on the right on the top are some
examples of these different
other different molecular machines that
we're able to find from nature's
diversity
this one here is cas9 this is the most
sort of widely used crispr protein for
editing
but then there are also other dna
editing machineries like
uh like cast 12 a and castor b
and also rna targeting machineries like
cascarine
and these come from all sorts of
bacteria some from human pathogens like
cas9
others from thermophilic bacteria like
asphalt b
or from from bacteria that live our gum
dental bacteria like the cancer team
so so they really come from everywhere
in nature
and then on the bottom right um is is
another
approach that we have been working on
for rna editing
rather than editing the dna uh it's also
possible to edit rna
and this has different functions as well
for therapeutic
applications where dna editing may not
be as easy to achieve
or or you may want the the effect to be
more transient rather than a permanent
effect so these are just some examples
what is super exciting is that
scientists are continuing to map
the world's natural diversity and by
diving deep into these diverse
dna or rna sequences we can find
many more interesting molecular machines
and turn them
into a useful therapeutic molecules
and so so we're really starting to look
at look at a
wealth of a really a treasure chest of
different machineries that we can
use to improve our health thank you
thank you fun so one follow-up question
and i remember i think i i was once
interviewing you and i like
tortured you on this because i couldn't
quite understand it when it comes to the
brain
why is it that rna
related editing seems to be
most important what are the advantages
why why is it so important that in the
crispr toolbox
we have these rna tools for the brain
yeah that's a really good question so um
for editing in the brain
there are there are a number of
different challenges one of them is that
editing the dna in in any cell
requires cells to be able to actively
replicate and divide
because the machineries or some of the
machineries involved in
those kinds of repair are are linked to
cell division
but brain cells don't divide and so
if you are to edit dna in the brain
in in different kinds of ways sometimes
you're limited because
of that lack of cell division rna
editing takes a different approach
where you don't rely on the cellular
machinery
you deliver everything you need to edit
dna right there
into the cells that you want to change
and you can go and make
very precise changes and also add very
high efficiency
the other aspect of rna editing is that
rna editing
can be transient so it provides
advantages where you don't want the
change to be there permanently
for example there are changes in a cell
an edit that you can make to rna in the
cell that can cause
cells to proliferate or to divide and
differentiate
you may not want to do that for forever
because you'll end up with a tumor
and too much cell growth and you want to
just pulse it
do it for for short window time and
that's where
um having rna editing which which
you know turns over after a short period
of time is also advantageous
but overall i think having a a broad
toolbox where you can do
many different types of changes to cells
it's going to be
the best because you can pick and choose
the most suitable
approach for the specific healthcare
problem that we're trying to tackle
so labeling what you're about to say
very clearly as many years away
and only a concept and just kind of your
imagination at work
but still how could you imagine using
rna editing
if let's say i have a brain disease like
parkinson's or autism or bipolar
disorder or depression
so um so one of the aspects that i
talked about
today are the are the cargos or the
payloads that we put into a delivery
system
but another major problem for brain
therapy is the vehicle itself how do we
build
the best rocket to be able to put into
the right brain cells
in the right part of the brain and and
that
i think a lot of scientists are working
on and we're also working on as well
will um will sort of complement all of
the editing machineries whether it's dna
or rna
to be able to treat a brain illness so
while this is not quite ready
yet i think in the coming decade we're
going to see
tremendous events both on the vehicle
and on the payload front
and that synthesis will will unleash
a lot of new therapeutics okay thank you
paulina i want to turn to you now so in
recent years your lab is focused on
designing and fabricating
smarter molecules that are equipped with
magnetic steering this is so cool to
enable guided
non-invasive delivery of drugs deep into
the brain
so can you talk a little bit about this
approach and the sorts of treatments
that
maybe it could help bring one day to the
clinic
you carrie so i'm just as fun i'm going
to share a few slides to help articulate
this point
so my group at mit designs magnetic
nanoparticles
and we use them as transducers of
signals to cells
so what are the magnetic nanoparticles
they're essentially specks
of material that is very similar to rust
and there are about maybe one five
thousands of your hair
in diameter and over the past
decade we have learned how to make them
in a variety of
shapes and sizes and materials for
example we can make little spheres
or icosahedrons but we can also make
disks
or even little donuts and this diversity
of properties translates into diversity
of functions
so what can magnetic particles do for
neurobiology
well because they are magnetic they
respond to magnetic field
and this is important because all
biological
tissues you and i and everyone on this
panel
v are transparent to magnetic field
and this means that all the fields can
go through us without
causing an effect or any kind of harm to
the tissue
and those fields that i'm talking about
are tiny they're not like a giant
magnetic resonance
imaging field there may be one thousands
of that
and this means we can use this fields to
trigger
different processes and deep inside the
body
remotely using our magnetic particles
for example a really tiny spherical
particles like these ones
can dissipate heat when
an alternating field is applied
externally
and that field oscillates really quickly
at the kilohertz rate
but this disk particles instead
can vibrate in a slowly varying magnetic
field
so now you can see how can we deliver
those signals
from far away but most importantly
all of these particles being magnetic
they can be moved around
these magnetic fields this means we can
inject them into the bloodstream and
guide them to the organ of
interest for example to the brain
and there we can place them in a direct
in the correct location to avoid any
kind of
side effects and to take advantage of
this magnetic delivery
we are proposing to package therapies
into magnetic nanobots together with our
magnetic particles
so what uh this the way we can design
this nanobots
is we can make this shell sensitive to a
stimulus for example a heat
or a vibration that we can deliver
remotely
and now we can envision a therapy
when a molecule or a drug is packaged
into this nanobot we then take this
nanobot
and we guide it to the brain to a
specific location
and then we apply a specific
magnetic signal that is going to trigger
either heating or vibration of this
little
engines and that will permeabilize our
nanabot and release
a therapeutic exactly where it is needed
so why is this important
well if you're thinking about most
common treatment
for neurological disorders or for mental
health conditions
those treatments usually involve drugs
those drugs are taken orally or injected
and they're not targeted which means
they go everywhere
and because they go everywhere they
can cause significant side effects for
instance antidepressants
may cause undesired weight gain or
weight loss
painkillers often are accompanied with
constipation
so but now imagine if i took a
therapeutic that targets a particular
brain circuit and deliver it
inside this magnetic carrier only to the
place where it is needed most
we can avoid all of those side effects
[Music]
altogether
beautiful so one clarifying question
um i understood how you can use these
nanobots to
deliver therapies to one particular part
of the brain or another but i didn't
understand
how the magnetic nanobots help you get
past the blood-brain barrier
so this is the money question kerry so
there
uh we have some ideas so specifically
uh the nanobots can
package molecules that when they're
heated up
which we can do with our nanoparticles
externally
those molecules fall apart and release a
gas
called nitric oxide and that a little
bit of that
gas can temporarily permeabilize
the barrier between blood and the brain
and that allows us to kind of
temporarily open this door
into the brain for the therapeutic to
follow the suit
got it very cool so what you're talking
about is
material science basically and so i
would imagine everything you just
described needs a great deal of
knowledge about the characteristics of
different materials as well as the
properties of the brain itself
can you give us an idea of the way you
think about these different
characteristics when you go about
creating new techniques
to treat brain disorders so
um this is uh this is exactly um
sort of our uh everyday business so
our group actually draws inspiration
from both
neurobiology and from physics to design
new magnetic materials and
we aspire to shift the focus from bulky
devices
that are large and are used in clinic
for therapies
as well as away from the drugs that have
undesirable side effects
towards therapies that really get at the
molecular
and circuit uh origins of actual
diseases so that we can treat
not the symptoms but the fundamental
underlying issues
and at the most fundamental level the
function of the nervous system is
largely governed by the workings of the
proteins that transport
ions across membranes of neurons
and this proteins are the gatekeepers of
neural activity
and if we can control those gatekeepers
then we can
treat neurological and mental health
conditions
from fundamental principles and it turns
out that those gatekeeper proteins
those iron transporters they're about
a few nanometers in size so also just
about one five thousands of your hair
and if we um
learn to con that means that the tools
um that we need to use to control this
um nanometer scale objects should also
operate a nanometer scale
and that's the inspiration for using
nanoparticles
but now think about these proteins these
gatekeepers
they all can be triggered by different
stimuli
some of them respond to chemicals drugs
others respond to heat
others respond to tension and now if we
design
our magnetic particles to transduce
signals from the magnetic field to any
of those stimuli
then we should be able to control those
molecules
wirelessly and non-invasively at the
nanoscale
so to accomplish this we start from
theoretical physics principles
to understand how different magnetic
materials
respond to different magnetic fields
that are safe
for for humans and animals
and then we turn to synthetic chemistry
to actually create those particles
and then finally we investigate their
materials properties
to compare the um uh
uh those results with our initial
predictions and the cycle goes on and on
until we finally identify a material
that can
act as a remote controller for one of
those
channels for those ion transporters or
that can act as an engine for those
magnetic nanobots
by guiding and delivering a molecular
therapeutic payload
where it is needed okay so i have about
a hundred questions on that but we're
going to have to let it go
and move on to ed your lab has developed
many new tools to visualize brain
activity at a scale we couldn't even
begin to imagine
just a few years ago how do these tools
that you've developed help scientists
overcome some of the biggest
challenges in developing new
therapeutics
thanks it's really great to be here as
part of the launch of this new center
um well the brain is really complicated
you know in a cubic millimeter of brain
tissue you have
a hundred thousand brain cells and the
connections between them
fine nanoscale connections they're about
a billion of those called synapses
and so if you want to understand a brain
disorder to the point where we can
targetedly uh fix it or remedy it we
have to know what's going on
you know there are thousands of genes in
the genome that change their expression
they can change the location of the gene
products what's really going on
in the brain so we've been working ways
to try to visualize
what are previously invisible things in
the brain
high speed activity nanoscale features i
can just show you a couple pictures
of the kinds of things that we're trying
to do
one big problem with the brain is that
brain cells and brain regions are large
objects macroscopic objects
but the wiring of the brain and the
biomolecules those gene products are
nanoscale
and often organized with nanoscale
precision how can you see something
that's nanoscale in the context of
something that's large
well about five years ago we announced
an interesting discovery we could take
brain specimens not living ones and
infuse them with a chemical that's a lot
like the stuff in baby diapers a
swallowable polymer
process the tissue just right and add
water and we can blow it up
so panel b here is a piece of the mouse
brain panel c
is the same piece of mouse brain tissue
about a day and a half later and we've
increased it in its size by about 100
fold in volume
what that means is you can see very fine
features in the brain like the wiring of
the brain
you can also look at the organization of
biomolecules and working with lots of
people now to try to figure out
in a variety of diseases and
neurological and psychiatric conditions
what are the molecular changes in the
brain
so the idea here is that we can make
these invisible nanoscale features
large and obvious we can bring the
invisible into the realm of the visible
but this only works on preserved brain
tissues not living ones
and so recent years we've also started
trying to evolve
molecules that can light up brain cells
when they are active this is difficult
because you need
to match the high speed of activity of
the brain and also
brain cells are delicate you have to be
able to watch them in action without
hurting them so just as the natural
world as fun outlined in the beginning
evolves molecules with interesting
properties can we evolve molecules in
the laboratory and we build robots to
let you do just that
to make molecules better towards some
goal
using these we are excited to try to
look at how the brain computations are
changing
in disease states so to summarize we're
very excited about
ways of looking at the structure of the
brain and the dynamics of the brain and
can we take those invisible
changes and make them obvious and now
we're doing a lot of work also in
computational strategies
machine learning and artificial
intelligence strategies to extract
the meaning from these very complex maps
could you figure out a new therapeutic
target by looking
at data that people have not been able
to see before
wow and uh what about do you have a
particular approach to the blood brain
barrier also and and what's your thought
process
on that sure well uh as i mentioned in
that little slide uh
we think a lot about how to automate um
evolution in the laboratory how do we
scale up
um the ability to evolve new molecules
that can do interesting things like
transport a payload
across the blood brain barrier or do
other important feats
in the realm of molecular therapeutics
and so one idea is
with these novel robots that allow us to
evolve molecules can we evolve a
molecule that will get
a certain payload across the blood-brain
barrier
you know nature is a great designer but
maybe we can try to recapitulate some of
the process that nature uses
in the laboratory and evolving molecules
towards
a goal can be very powerful because
sometimes we don't know what we want
however we know where we want to go and
so we can try to coax these molecules
along that evolutionary path by making
lots of mutations
selecting for the mutants that are
better for a certain goal
and then repeating that process over and
over again
that totally makes sense thank you and
last but very much
not least gulping thing um coming to us
from shanghai by the way
so he gets extra points gulping mice
have been the primary model for disease
research in the scientific world for
over
a century but there are growing concerns
that the brains of mice are just not
close enough to our own and that this
could be a key reason why progress in
developing new treatments
for brain diseases has largely stalled
and hasn't totally still but it's not
going as quickly as we'd like so can you
talk a little bit about
new understandings of brain activity at
the level of
single cells and how that could be
helping scientists make progress in
developing new treatments
sure thank you carrie um so i want to
also show us slides just
to illustrate this so um you know
in the field of neuroscience most of our
studies are based on mice but
as we all know mice are very different
in their brain structure and function
to the human brains and
so one of the key thing is in the human
brain the biggest
part of our brain actually is called
prefrontal cortex
this is the most important part of
control our higher cognitive function
like working memories or emotions and
the
mice are rats which is the most commonly
used
models they barely have this part
so then you can tell if we want to study
brain disorders which would all
often involve the dysfunction of higher
brain functions
and it's really difficult to study them
and you can also imagine
without this part of brain they are
bringing circuits
everything is very different so it's
harder to translate into clinical into
human studies so
the only you know fan fans i already
talked about
the crispr technology basically allow us
now have new models
much closer to human brain function or
at the cellular level for example we can
take the human skin cells and turn into
neurons
from the patient or from the you know
healthy individual turning into neurons
now we can
use crispr make it exact same mutations
and that
another important aspect is now we can
go beyond the models of our mice we can
make
non-human primary models which will be
much closer to our
our human brains so with this kind of
new model
now we can actually doing at the really
you know discover new target for
molecular therapy
so now with the new single cell
technology you basically can compare
the gene expressing changes at any
different
at a different time development of time
and at
every single cell in the brain you can
know
what is change what has been changed
during development
what has been changed during the disease
progress
and what is changed at the end of so at
the end you will know exactly what is
neural circuits and what a cell type has
been changed
now you can with this knowledge you know
which cells or which cell types i need
to target
to you know to let's say treat
depression
or stop the progression of alzheimer's
disease so these are now
it's you know it's not here yet but you
can see
in the near future scientists will be
able to develop a very specific
molecular target
and they treat this kind of brain
disorders
that makes so much sense because mice
are they really are so
so different we desperately needed new
models so
another question sort of related we know
that
certain symptoms cut across multiple
brain disorders for instance we see
obsessive thoughts in ocd and anxiety
and autism spectrum disorders
insomnia in parkinson's and depression
and other diseases
can you tell us about how scientists are
creating treatments that may be
effective for
multiple diseases with overlapping
symptoms
rather than just treating each disease
as a separate diagnosis
yeah that's not really a very good
question also a very cutting edge
question so
so the field you know in neuroscience
field
both basic scientists and clinical
scientists now we're thinking this very
differently
it's not you know the reason is
not only clinical evidence but also
their molecular cellular genetic
evidence now with
large-scale genetic studies which
contribute into many of the
neural brain disorders especially
psychiatric disorders
many of the risk genes are overlapping
between these disorders
so the approach now is thinking
it's instead of just studying individual
the disease individual disorders
individually now we study cross-border
look at
what are common and for example
you mentioned you know let's say
sleep disruptions they're coming in you
know in depression
in schizophrenia in autism other
neurodevelopment disorders
but they all have in the brain if we
understand the neuroscience
they all control by the particular
circuits that regulate
our sleep so if we can
have a very specific target to modulate
the sleep
then it can be used cross
disorders instead of for individual just
for sleep
disruption but you can also use it for
neurodevelopment disorders
or for depression patients similar
things for obsessive compare
compile some sores or other symptoms so
got it totally makes sense okay we now
move on to audience questions
again you're welcome to type your
question into the q a below the video
stream
or to upvote any question that someone
has already asked by clicking
on the thumbs up icon next to it we've
gotten quite a few questions
already um several are about how
crispr can be used to protect against
alzheimer's is there a way we could use
crispr to engineer
ourselves to be resistant to diseases
of aging like alzheimer's um fung i
think that's for you unless anybody else
wants it
yeah thank you carrie i'll start maybe
goping can join me as well
i think one of the biggest challenges
for alzheimer's
is understanding the the
different contributors to the disease
process
how do genetics contribute how do
different mutations
inherited or otherwise contribute to
alzheimer's disease
and how do other environmental factors
and
epigenetic changes contribute to
alzheimer's
i think being able to use crispr um to
treat alzheimer's is still
in the in the in the future but in the
meantime scientists are
already using crispr to map and identify
the function of different
genetic mutations and understand how
they contribute
to alzheimer's or brain degeneration and
i think by using these kinds of
genetic editing approaches like crispr
we can start to unravel the mechanism
and then maybe a number of years from
now we'll be able to
um use that understanding to be able to
develop treatment
uh so so it's gonna be a little little
ways off but
um but christopher is playing a role in
advancing the
the speed of the discoveries like i
could imagine if you have the apoe4
gene that inclines you gives you a a
predisposition toward alzheimer's you
would want to fix it
did you want to add anything to that
yeah sure
so i so this is something we have been
thinking
as many um for giving example i think
from the preventive point of view is
actually really interesting point
so there are studies now uh uh study
people who live over 100 years old but
they are still
extremely healthy and as sharp as you
know
young people so why these people are so
resistant
right so so that study have identified a
few
really key genes are different
from them so their genes if you don't
have that
that kind of expression patterns then
you are
protected so these could be potentially
in the future use gene therapy to modify
them
that mimic the condition of being these
very
long-lived healthy people with very you
know
clear brain or clear mind so that's a
direction many people are looking at
them now i think
we're accumulating more and more data
use these technologies of course you
want to model them being animals
models how this can you know improve the
uh you know brain function and whether
this can be applied in the future this
is still a long way ago but we do have
some directions now from human genetic
data
interesting speaking for myself i hope
that work is done very quickly
because i need it sooner rather than
later which brings me to a question that
is coming from the audience
what is the time horizon to start using
molecular therapies um
i don't i don't know exactly who that
should go to
whooping maybe you again or does anybody
else want to volunteer
fine yeah so i can start i think you
know um
maybe paulina and the aventa and the
attacking
chimney so it would depend on so
there are many different ways to think
about the molecular therapeutics if we
think about the
molecular therapeutics for cell type
specific modification you know
modulation
for a particular symptom that's actually
within next
five years we will have things you know
not necessarily
exactly from this center but maybe
facilitated by some discovery from this
center
and to go into clinical trials because
we neuroscientists have been studying
the brain function for a long time just
they were not
there was not a easy way to identify
cell type specific targets now we can
identify them and we advance the model
animal models we can test them in models
first then move on to clinic the other
aspect actually we see a lot of future
is a very specific targeted we call the
monogenic
um you know uh brain disorders for
example the about
25 percent of neurodevelopment disorder
including severe autism spectrum
disorder
they are caused by single gene mutation
we can fix that and these are also we
can see in the next five years
some of them will go into clinical
trials actually we
my lab is working with some groups at
the broader institute and with
fentanyl i'll try to develop ways that
we can testing animal models and
cellular models and move
on into so we i'm very excited about
this center and this made it possible
to make it possible to test all these
things and we're seeing that
you know at least in our lifetime really
moving some of it into clinics
so actually i just like to follow up on
that because that was a very striking
thing that you said so basically if 25
of autism spectrum disorders roughly are
single gene
disorders you're saying that within the
next several years you should be able to
use gene editing or some other molecular
therapy to
what to treat those disorders in a way
that could
what produce yeah so yeah so
um of course not all of them but some of
them
are already in the preclinical
development actually we can
either dramatically improve them or
actually
potentially cure them because for this
very severe neural development disorder
and the especially with intellectual
disability and
it will be very hard for them to have
independent life so our goal is to
improve that make it possible for them
to live an independent life like
we do and so the by fixing their
genetics because we know they are
monogenic
they are single gene mutations these are
very severe
and if we can change that gene back to
normal
depend on when if you change it early
enough
you know very when they're very young
our brains are very plastic
then the the you know the correct the
the correct the cells will take over and
make
new connections and correct all the
problems so
you will see a very dramatic improvement
we already see
in animal models so now that is
how do we make this safely into humans
in the next five years
striking um does anybody else want to
talk about time
horizon uh paulina ed
so let me add um to
a different perspective to what uh
goping
was talking about so some of the types
of tools that we are working on
could be um either on the earlier
scale of development or facilitate some
of the tools that go up in and fungi
developing
and kind of accelerate that process as
well
so uh for example the
magnetic carriers that we are working
with the magnetic particles
uh we are using are very similar to
already
clinically approved contrast agents used
for mri
it's just it's a a better formulation
that is tuned
to do a different uh different work
different job
but chemically it's quite similar so
from approval
standpoint maybe it will help and then
from
if you're using those um magnetic
carriers
to deliver drugs that are already
approved but do so more precisely
to avoid the side effects that may be
the first
step for improving molecular therapeutic
or delivering them exactly where they're
needed
on a more sort of longer uh horizon
and we can help uh for example guaping
and
fung to deliver genetic tools
to exa to again to locations where
they're needed
if we're interested in for example
modifying
gene inside the brain we don't
necessarily want to modify that gene
everywhere and we don't necessarily want
to flush the entire
organism of this very large load of a
viral vector
so what we could do is to package
the viral vectors into magnetic carriers
and then use the magnetic fields to
guide them
where those vectors are needed so that
they can do their job
and fix that mutation in the correct
location in the brain or anywhere else
in the body
lovely so you can all kind of synergize
with each other the work that you're
doing
paulina just to stay with you for one
question this question is getting a lot
of
upvotes are there proteins in nature
that respond to electromagnetic fields
like
some animals use for migration that
could be cloned and used in magnetic
nanobots
so this is a fascinating question and
my group has been thinking about it for
for a while
and there's um has been quite a bit of
controversy in the field about
magnetic response of a naturally
occurring proteins
uh despite decades of vigorous research
we still don't actually understand
how the organisms uh sense magnetic
field for example how do pigeons
navigate or how do even
insects navigate there are some
hypotheses that are based
on um symmetries
that are associated not really this
magnetic particles but
more with magnetic response of molecules
that have been implicated in this
magnetoreception
but generally those mechanisms rely on
light
and it's very difficult to deliver light
into the for example to deep brain
without implants and i'm
sure ed can comment uh more on that
uh there are magnetotactic bacteria in
in nature that make beautiful magnetic
nanoparticles that
definitely rival any synthetic chemist
however the genes for to create
those magneto magnetosomes inside
mammalian cells require quite
sophisticated engineering
because most of those bacteria are
actually anaerobic
so uh they don't do well with oxygen
however i mean it is uh definitely worth
considering if
uh we could
teach our cells to make the
nanoparticles themselves
then maybe we wouldn't need to involve
the synthetic chemist but instead
uh use the biology that said uh to be
continued yeah to be continued
thank you um ed first of all do you want
to add anything to that
and second of all here's a juicy
question for you how long does your lab
pursue a crazy
idea before you realize it's not
possible to implement right now
or are ideas pursued year after year
well i i couldn't say it better than
what you've already heard from our
fantastic
experts and collaborators on on the
timeline to the clinic
it's really great to be part of this
amazing team
as far as the process of uh
innovation that's something i like to
think about actually because
um there's often a big gap between the
knowledge
that an idea is possible or at least not
impossible and the wisdom to know that
it's a good idea
um so this expansion idea for example um
we originally had the idea in our group
back in 2006 2007
um but we didn't realize that it was a
really important idea until we tried
lots of methods of nano-imaging and
found out that they were very slow
it was hard to imagine how they would
scale up to a large complex brain
circuit
and so in 2012 um two grad students in
my group who actually were working on
nano imaging and getting frustrated with
how slow it was
we started working on the expansion
project then so one thing that we do a
lot of is what i call failure rebooting
sometimes
there's knowledge but not yet wisdom or
sometimes an idea
that's been around for a while suddenly
the world's different and it becomes
valuable i mean we hear a lot about
machine learning nowadays
a lot of the mathematics goes back to
the 80s and 90s
but with big data and faster computing
machine learning is now suddenly
able to go at a much faster pace and so
we see this example throughout the
sciences and engineering fields
so is there anything that you see coming
in the immediate future where the two
things are coming together the wisdom
and the knowledge to explode into
something beautiful yeah yeah well we're
thinking a lot now about
imaging the living brain that's a very
difficult thing to do because
you need to deal with the delicacy of
neurons and not interfere with the
normal function
and getting fast three-dimensional
multimodal
images of the brain is very challenging
and so
right now we are very actively uh trying
to figure out are there new
tricks or hacks that we could bring into
the field of live brain imaging and
hopefully that will be very useful for
revealing
the coordination between signals in the
brain you know there's many many things
going on in the brain at once so that's
one of the reasons that molecular
therapeutics
is challenging where in the network do
you want to intervene
if you can watch five or ten or more
things at once
and say oh that one happens first or
those three things always go together
then you can start to see the patterns
and that's something that we're working
very hard towards right now
fun quick question what are the ongoing
crispr clinical trials meant to treat
and are there any results yet
yeah um so crispr or cas9 has already
been applied in
in two different clinical trials one of
them is for the treatment of blood
sickle cell type of disorders like
thalassemia and also
just sickle cell last year a cambridge
based company called crispr therapeutics
i released data from two patients
one of them is a thalassemia patient and
have found that
they were able to elevate the the level
of
sort of fetal chemoglobal expression and
then the
patients are or have been
transfusion-free
so they didn't have to go into the
hospital so that was a very promising
a result for for the whole field edit
house medicine
which i helped to co-found have
dosed a patient with an aav carrying
cas9
into the eye to target a mutation that
leads to blindness
and and that trial is also progressing
so those are the two that are inhuman
already but there are a number of other
trials that
i think are under are being developed
and marching toward
clinical testing so i think in the
coming
few years we're going to see more and
more applications
and then certainly as safety data and
also efficacy data come back
from these initial trials especially for
sickle cell disease and also for for
blindness
i think developer drug developers will
be able to
further uh refine the system and be able
to go after more
more indications thank you
question for gloping adverse childhood
experiences and toxic stress
change the developing brain especially
in children ages birth to age five
will there be a role for molecular
therapeutics in this area
ah that's a really good question this is
actually exactly some of the
things we are very interested in it is
you know in animal model studies
well known that if you really uh stress
out
and during development
you will make permanent change in the
brain exactly how
what are changes we need at the
expansion microscope
really figure out which part you know
what exactly the change is not
grossly like abnormal but it's just this
refinement of neural circuits if you
think about
all humans all animals when we were born
all the subjects there the connection
already made
but it's refined right so so
everything's refined that's why how you
that's why your experience
makes you a very unique specific
so so if if you think about
the environment change let let's say you
know adverse events or all these things
it will really significantly impact your
brain development
in the eye then once that's all the
development has
called a critical window once you pass
that it's much harder to change
so that's why you will have permanent
change or damage to the
child brain so so the question is
to figure out is what is that a window
and how can we
what is the change let's say you know
add a figure our way how
imaging the neuronal activity in the
whole brain in life
without the damages then we can figure
out which part is wrong
and we can go in and fix it and it
basically you were permanent
so these are things that can be done in
animal models now
partially still another image in the
whole brain activity
but part of our part by based on our
knowledge we can go imaging it
so in the future if this can be done in
humans
imaging figure out which path is
actually affected
then we can potentially to permanently
fix it if
we treat it at the right time during
development
so so there is a critical there is a
critical window but it is
also a postnatal window that means there
is a period of time
our brain is very plastic even something
goes wrong there is a chance
you can go fix it and permanently fix it
so we can we need to catch that window
i think about that a lot with covet with
the pandemic and
a lot of kids missing their usual
windows in terms of school and
yeah okay uh we only have about three or
four minutes left i'd like to end with a
lightning round
which is um there's a great question
that came in and i'd like to ask each of
the panelists what your
less than one minute answer is so the
question
is what do you think will be the first
brain disorder that will be
cured but i'd like to shift the question
a little bit and say what do you think
will be the first brain disorder that
will be cured with
molecular therapeutics so um fun why
don't you take it first
okay i'll give it a try um so i think
um the the ones that are most tractable
are the ones where
we have a relatively clear understanding
of the disease mechanism
so monogenetic diseases or inherited
genetic diseases
like huntington's fragrance ataxia
are are going to be more attractable
because they are single
target and we can design a therapeutic
against those
so so my my thinking is that those will
be the first wave
of treatments great thank you uh
paulina so uh
i'm i would give it a guess something
that
we already have a good drug therapy for
but where uh side effects are really
debilitating and we can avoid them
so a couple of examples uh good examples
would be
depression and parkinson's
great thank you ed
yeah so this is a um a tough question i
think uh polina
and fung have already done a great job
of addressing it i guess
where where our group comes in is often
through our imaging strategies as group
was alluding to earlier how can we put
the other diseases
on the same playing field can we map out
systematically the changes
so we do have insights into mechanisms
and
there are lots of conditions of course
which are not monogenetic or for which
we don't have a good candidate but if we
can
try to get detailed molecular maps um of
gene expression and protein content and
nano organization at scale
um can we use machine learning to
pinpoint new targets so i know i know
i'm not answering your question
but this is kind of how we think about
it in our group is you know there's a
lot of people where
where we don't currently know how to
help them and if we can try to tackle
those diseases so we're looking at
alzheimer's right now
we're looking at parkinson's disease
looking at a variety
of conditions where there there might be
many things in in
a delicate interplay it's so complex
it's just
it's always whenever i report on the
brain i end up saying oh god it's so
complex
so yeah so for cure i think the
my view is the um earliest will come
from some of the neurodevelopment
disorders because they are
some of them are monogenic and our brain
are much more plastic during
during development so if we treat them
early enough we can actually have a
really
probably a real cure for some of the
monogenic neuroenvironment disorders
including severe autism spectrum
disorders
got it thank you so i want to thank
all of our panelists so much i the
pleasant surprise for me was not that
you were each doing amazing research but
how much it all can
interplay and interact and and synergize
uh in in various ways so i think we're
about to put up on the screen
a slide that will let people know how to
remain
involved and connected with the new
yangtan
center um and uh so there
there you have it bookmark it and i want
to
extend just my greatest thanks to all of
our panelists for being with us
and it's been a pleasure to be with all
of you and thank you